It goes along with my book,
which is basically making the argument that belief in non-human intelligence or
ETS, or UFO's UAPs, whatever you want to call them is a new form of religion.
And how's that work with the, the scientific method.
Do you think there's always this role of religion as being in his broad
definition of religion as being a compliment to our sort of very rigorous,
empirical pursuit of understanding reality,
there's always going to be this coupling will always define redefine new
areas of civilization, of what that religion actually looks like.
So you talk about technology and so on being the modern set of religious
beliefs around that, is it, so is that always going to, is religion,
is religion always going to kind of cover the space of things?
We can't quite understand what science yet,
but we still want to be thinking about.
Oh, I see what you're saying. That's a great question. When you say religion,
I would,
I would use the word religiosity because I think that we're moving
out of the dogmatic types of religions into more of a,
I hate to put it this way, but an X-Files type religion where we can say,
I want to believe, or the truth is out there. Right.
But we don't know that it's out there or we don't, we don't know yet what it is,
but we know it's out there. So there's this, um, this kind of built-in, um,
capacity for belief and something that we don't have evidence for
yet. And that's the sort of faith. So I would say yes to that question.
Absolutely. I think it's adaptive in that way. We're moving into a new, I mean,
heck removed. We've already moved into this culture.
Most people have not caught up with it yet. I see that in the school systems,
you know, and I think that, um,
I'm hoping we can catch up fast
cause really it's moving faster than we are.